today we're talking about the google
cloud 2021 summit series and some
exciting news for data lovers
i'm ryan and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
the google cloud 2021 summit series
kicked off last week with data cloud
financial services and applied ml up
next is the digital manufacturers summit
and we've got even more in store for you
throughout the summer be sure to
bookmark the summit series website and
register for free today
we are excited to announce dataplex an
intelligent data fabric that provides a
way to centrally manage monitor and
govern your data across
data lakes data warehouses and data
marks and make this data securely
accessible to a variety of analytics and
data science tools
dataplex provides an integrated
analytics experience bringing together
the best of google cloud and open source
tools
so you can rapidly curate secure
integrate and analyze data at scale
dataflow is a no-op serverless data
processing platform
that enables you to collect and enrich
the vast amounts of data that your
applications and users generate
we've built dataflow prime to bring
unparalleled resource utilization and
radical operational simplicity
to big data processing dataflow prime
allows you to get it more done
with less by eliminating the time you
spend sizing resource needs
optimizing resource usage to save costs
and increasing your productivity
check out the preview in early q3
for anyone who's found sharing and
exchanging data to be a challenge
we're excited to introduce analytics hop
a new fully managed service available q3
in preview
that helps you unlock the value of data
sharing leading to new insights and
increased business value
check out the blog for a full list of
capabilities today
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see the full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you